so there's this governor on our lives
that it is a governor and it's a it's
your identity it's this internal it's
what you think you're worth it's what
you think you deserve and the problem
for good people see we all know someone
right now in our life where we have
who's not ethical who's not a good
person who's winning and you're like I
can't believe they're getting it right
why can't I I'm a good person I treat
people while I'm honest here's the
reason why
by the way the unethical person
eventually karma you reap what you sow
comes home to roost but if you're a good
person this is so important people
understand this because it took me a
long time a good person in any endeavor
will only take from it what they think
they deserve what they think they're
worth in other words if there was a
pizza here you're a good person you
don't take all 12 pieces a good person
thinks there should be an equitable
distribution bigger so I might take
seven or eight arm-wrestle you I don't
know about that you're a moose but but
long story short what is is that you a
good person will not take more from the
table of life than they think they're
worth or they think they deserve and so
you have this governor on your identity
so what happens is our it's like a
thermostat our lives get going
we start doing really well if we're a 75
degree or and our life gets to 85 and 90
degrees unconsciously we go we don't
know we're doing it oh we start to cool
life back down to get it back to where
we're comfortable that reverse is also
true when things start to go really bad
and you're broke and you're struggling
you find a way to heat your life back up
to what you think you're worth and you
deserve so the way we alter our life is
sure we got alter our behavior and our
relationships and our circumstances but
the only way it's permanent is that we
alter that governor that thermostat and
we start to believe we're worth
eighty-five degrees of life 95 degrees
of life 110 degrees of life and there's
ways we can alter that how do we alter
it a couple different ways a one is what
you just said is that you put yourself
in circumstances that are demanding if
you pass what you think your capacity is
and when you succeed at them you build a
new water line you do you throw yourself
out there past where you're comfortable
and you and you do in 85 degrees
behavior and you knock it out of the
park and you go your brain starts to
believe it repetitiously when you start
doing that you build a new line now
you're 85 degrees that's number one
the second way though is Association if
you are around people and whatever that
endeavor is if it's a sport you're in or
if it's a business or your faith or your
peace if you begin to associate with
people who live in that space at a
higher temperature than you through
association you get heated up yeah so if
you're an athlete for example you're a
70-degree athlete and you start training
all the time with 85 and 90 degrees your
identity through osmosis goes up if your
person is trying to improve their faith
in their life or their their personal
piece about them you all know this
you've seen it when you start to hang
around people that are a little bit more
peaceful than you or meditate a little
bit more through that association over
time the thermostat changes in that area
and so it's both behaving in certain way
and then your associations yeah I
believe that I had a really good friend
of mine I went to lunch and he said I
don't know who this guy is here in front
of me and he goes let me ask you a
question honestly right now what are you
grateful for and at the lunch I said jex
nothing brother
there's nothing good in my life right
now and I'm not exaggerating this to you
when I tell you this and this is a
factual story as I'm mouthing these
words two people walked in with an older
man both of them clearly were fighting
cancer somehow both had lost their hair
one of the ladies had a bonnet on and
they were barely moving in both walked
by our table and gave me the most warm
greeting the warmest smile as a stranger
and he goes that's pretty freaking
pathetic you can't find anything in your
life to be grateful for right now and on
the drive home I'm not kidding you I
started to stack gratitude I started to
taking inventory because if you can find
things to be grateful for him that space
man as your life going to be rich when
there really are external things to be
grateful for
so my first mechanism out of that space
was honestly to stack the things I was
grateful for and I started reinforcing
it over and over and over again and what
happens is there's this reticular
activating system in our brains right
and all of a sudden because that's the
messaging I was giving myself all of a
sudden all these things start to come
into my awareness that I'm grateful for
I start to magnetized to myself some
people that I needed to find into my
life and that was the next layer I
started to see things to be grateful for
my health my fitness people who loved me
what it is it changed my
State when I stacked gratitude I changed
what I did in the morning and I changed
what I did in the evening and so somehow
by grabbing control of my morning and by
grabbing control of my evening I got
some measure of control over the middle
of my day I was an out of control person
back in those days meaning this I woke
up worried stressed fearful and I
immediately started thinking about a
bill I had to pay something that was
wrong and I'm in a state of reaction to
begin every sound talk within six
minutes of waking up six seconds most
people listening to this that's what
they do I said I got to grab control of
my morning and I set up routines in my
morning
maybe they serve me maybe they didn't
but they were things I could deliver on
doing for myself and so not only did
that give me control over the day but I
started to stack my self-confidence -
the key to self-confidence is really
simple and it is this is absolutely I've
trained hundreds of thousands of people
have spoken to millions of people around
the world I could tell you this the
self-confident people I know whether
they are athletes school teachers
mechanics parents stay-at-home moms you
name it they have a pattern of keeping
promises they make to themselves though
groundwork of beginning to build
self-confidence is to begin to keep the
promises you make to you and that's why
it's important to begin to even make
small promise you're gonna get up at a
certain time in the morning not only do
it but then give yourself credit say I
did what I said I was gonna do if it's
in your diet or your fitness don't just
eat the healthy foods go I'm doing what
I said I was going to do you begin to
build this reputation if you're
constantly being influenced and moved by
what other people think about you it
means there's a deficiency in what you
think about you and so the key is not
some you know and so so tarik like
belief system it's a pattern of keeping
the promises that you make to you that's
the groundwork of self-confidence for
sure and it is a pattern with when I
meet people that lack confidence I think
let me serve you let's begin to keep the
promises you make to you you're so
worried about there's this addiction to
other people's approval in the world
right it's the greatest the greatest
addiction today
it used to be drugs before that it was
alcohol there's all these addictions sex
addictions whatever the number one
addiction in the world today is the
addiction to other people's approve
and that's because we don't approve of
ourselves or we don't feel a spirit a
universe a God that we believe in that
approves of us and so my confidence
comes from both my faith and him the
fact that I keep promises I make to
myself that's the groundwork of all
confidence hmm there's a Malcolm X quote
that you really like tell me what it is
and why it's so powerful that which you
do not hate you will eventually tolerate
and I think that identifies most
people's lives in other words they
average becomes sort of like this slow
asphyxiation it's almost like an
anesthetic and that over time would
become kind of immune and dulled to the
average that we're becoming I know this
is true at least for me you probably
experienced it yourself too and so over
time we sort of minimize where we're at
in other words I'm a little pudgy
instead of being know your fat ass right
you know you don't magnify the degree to
which the pain ought to be affecting you
and so really what he means on that is
listen you're gonna get out of your life
what you'll accept that's really
difficult for people I think to
understand is look what you think you're
worth and what you're gonna tolerate is
absolutely what you're gonna bring into
your life and what the outward part of
your life is gonna look like and so I
live by that like I let myself sort of
feel the pain and the difficulty of
being not where I want to be in whatever
that areas were those would be my
spirituality my relationships my money I
let myself feel that pain cuz as you
know there's two motivators right
there's the gaining of pleasure right
wanting to go get something chasing the
dream but then there's the avoidance of
pain and for a lot of champions that's a
pretty big driving force for them and so
at least for me I I leveraged both of
those things on me to get myself to take
action the elite performers look at time
and use time completely differently than
the people who perform at an average
level the first thing I want to tell you
about people who win who max out they
are in a much bigger hurry than the
people who are average and I'm not
kidding you when I say this they're in a
bigger hurry to get to their destination
to get to their outcome their pace is
faster they walk faster they talk faster
and their expectation where they're
gonna arrive at their destination is
sooner this may seem like a very small
subtle thing but I want you to evaluate
how big of a hurry are you in because
there's something to be said about how
close you think you are to a goal
and how fast you will run to get to the
finish line let me give an example of
that if you and I started out right now
and we had a 26 mile marathon to run
right in our minds it was 26 miles we're
gonna race each other we would pace
ourselves at a certain speed in order to
maintain that speed because of the
duration of the run so it was a marathon
we'd jog wouldn't we pretty slowly you
certainly wouldn't sprint 26 miles and
so because the destination because the
finish line is so far away our pace or
our hurry is limited based on how far
away we think we are or when we'll
arrive there but if you and I were to
run a hundred yard dash with the pace be
the same because the finish line is so
much closer we'd run full-speed from the
minute we took off wouldn't we because
of the proximity of how close the finish
line is the people that win in life
don't necessarily have more vision than
you see it's not a lack of vision always
that means that you are going to lose
it's a lack of a type of vision which is
depth perception you think you're
further away from the outcome and so you
pace yourself like it and you jog all
the time throughout your life the people
that win may have a bigger vision but
they have accurate depth perception they
understand how close their goals are how
close their outcome is and they're
constantly in a sprint to get there
throughout their day
that means consequently they get started
earlier and they finish later they get
up earlier throughout the day they're in
a bigger hurry to get to the places they
need to be because the finish line and
their mind is so much closer I cannot
emphasize this enough to you is just the
pace and the way time shrinks for elite
performers compared to the average I'm
telling you the average performer could
say the same things read the same books
have the same schedule yet the person
who is in a bigger hurry throughout the
day ends up winning the day winning the
week winning the month winning the year
and winning the life I'm addicted to one
more and so I want your much we're going
forward to be one more what does that
look like if we're working out that
means when we're in the gym and we say
I'm gonna do five sets of 10 I'm crazy
like I'm a psycho cuz I want to win
I want to be somebody I want to separate
I want to compete and the way I do that
isn't with my giftedness because I
wasn't born with a bunch of gifts and I
think gifts are crap I think for the
most part gifted people struggle in life
because things come easy them I like the
things haven't come easy for me in my
life I like to have natural talents in
every area and maybe you like that about
you too maybe you've looked at yourself
all your life and thought man I don't
have that natural beauty or that natural
talent or this gift for creativity or
intellect or humor I don't have any of
those things but what I got is that will
outwork you and so at the gym one of the
things I focus on they say it's five
sets of ten when I'm at ten I go one
more BAM eleven if I'm running on the
treadmill and it's a 45-minute run I
never finish at 45 I always go one more
minute 46 if I'm at the office and I'm
supposed to make 25 phone calls that day
when I'm at the end of the day I always
do one more if I've got meetings I
always do one more my mantra for three
decades in business has been one more
how bad do you want your goal right now
I think there's a lot of people in the
world today because it's really nice
thing to talk about I want this this is
my outcome this is my goal like how bad
you were do you want as bad as breathing
do you want it as bad as anything you've
ever wanted in your life and if you
calibrate it at the highest enough
levels where I found the people that are
the hungriest they find a way when you
know why you want something when it's
desperation the power of being desperate
is something that most people avoid they
think desperation is a weakness and I'm
here to tell you desperation is one of
the most powerful emotions you could
possibly possess because when you're
desperate you find reserves and
reservoirs of ideas talents and a
strength that you don't know you have
when you find yourself in a desperate
situation so ironically the one thing
most people avoid in their life hunger
which is caused by being desperate when
you're starving you become desperate
think of somebody who's starving on the
street they've got to how resourceful
would you get if your children were
literally starving and you had to feed
them right so the number one thing we
need more than anything to win is hunger
which comes from a state of desperation
yet we're constantly trying to comfort
ourselves in the real world to avoid the
state of being desperate and I'm telling
you that I think you need to embrace
desperation again in your life like do
you want it so bad that you're desperate
for it see in a fight you show me to
people this is why it's so hard to
repeat as a champion in the fighting
game because you show me someone who's
up-and-coming who's hungry for that
title who's never had it before
who can taste it who knows if they win
that belt their whole life's gonna
change they're gonna be champion of the
world all the endorsements all the money
all their family life all their parents
lives are gonna change you show me
somebody chasing that hungry for it
against someone who's just trying to
hold on to a title and that's why most
of the time the challenger beats the
champ it's hard to repeat as a champion
because the hunger goes down just a
little bit the greatest athletes the
Kobe's the Bradys the Jordans of sports
have a way of feeding their hunger all
the time and increasing it what
separates them isn't just their work
ethic isn't just their talent although
those things matter isn't just they
practice more what separates them as
they're just hungrier they somehow find
a way as they climb up the ranks and win
championship to get even hungrier for
more where 99% of the athletes lose just
a little bit of their edge once they get
that first championship that first pro
contract that first big amount of money
that first world championship they just
lose their hunger a little bit and then
there's the elite they get hungrier it
feeds the beast you get to choose your
life you get to choose how you feel not
other people there's these illusions in
life we really can't control anything
other than our own thoughts our own
behavior our own patterns we can't
control what other people do say or
think
and it's this illusion of control often
times that we can somehow manipulate
other people or manipulate situations
that cause us to fall into these
patterns but what we do have the power
of in life is we have the power to
choose and I say this to you because I'm
somebody just like you I struggle with
the different patterns I have some of
them serve me some of them don't
I sometimes engage in thoughts that
don't create the right emotion
for me that don't serve me I know what
it's like to be frustrated and angry and
depressed and down and lost and fearful
and worried worries a big one for me
I love to fall into a pattern of worry
when certain circumstances begin to
happen it creates a trigger and a
pattern in me a man do I love to worry
and so I give you these tools and
resources because these are things I to
struggle with I've been able to overcome
them by just being aware and choosing
and so the first thing is the power of
choice finish this sentence for me I
choose to be blissful rather than blank
I choose to be blissful rather than
blank what would your answer be one of
the emotions I challenge you to
experience more of in life is bliss you
know we are the calibration of maybe the
five emotions we experience on a regular
basis and so if you're experiencing
depression frustration worry fear
anxiety pain on a regular basis you can
have one life they're experiencing bliss
and fulfillment and ecstasy and joy and
in your life and contribution
recognition and significance if you're
experiencing love experience those
emotions you have a totally different
life we have the power to choose which
emotions we want to experience I want
you to remember something comparison is
the pathway to unhappiness I'm telling
you that in every area of your life
where you find unhappiness you will find
comparison in fact the antithesis to
that is also true when there is no
comparison
you cannot create unhappiness in your
life that's a pretty bold and powerful
statement but it's true we only feel
unhappy in our lives when we compare
something to maybe something in our life
that was a different time maybe perhaps
when we were wealthier or in a different
relationship where we were healthier in
some level comparing our current
conditions to previous ones that
comparison is what creates the
unhappiness that's actually not the
condition itself or perhaps you're in a
relationship where you compare it to a
previous relationship you had and how
they treat it or how you felt at that
time perhaps you compare this time in
your life just to us simply a different
time
that comparison will always create
unhappiness in your life if you can
remove yourself from comparing both
yourself to a previous time in your life
a previous condition a previous
situation or even comparing yourself to
other people in your life this is a
recipe and a formula for unhappiness
every single time in your life where
you're experiencing unhappiness you are
doing a comparison to something
it's the contradiction between your
current situation
current relationship current body
current finances current anything and
something exterior either a previous
time in your life a previous person your
life or are you comparing yours to
someone else's it is an insidious
disease that so many people in society
suffer from today particularly because
of the advent of social media we watched
someone's video of what they're doing on
a Friday night and it's not what they're
doing that makes us unhappy it's
comparing what they're doing to what
we're doing that makes us unhappy do you
ever think about what you think about
because if you did and if you took
control of that you could alter the
direction of your entire life most
people never take the time to take an
inventory about their thoughts yet our
thoughts control our world our thoughts
are like magnets they literally draw
towards us that's which we obsess about
and so most people never take the time
to analyze what they think about the
most successful people I know are the
most self-aware meaning they're aware of
what they do and they're also aware what
they think they're aware of how they're
perceived average person you and I have
about 75,000 thoughts a day rattling
around in this thing we call our brains
in our mind 75,000 of them the crazy
thing is 91% of those thoughts are
identical to the previous day and
identical to the day before that and the
day before that and the day before that
and then we wonder why our life seems to
repeat itself over and over again so
really the difference in our life if we
have 75,000 thoughts today here's the
crazy thing
91% of them are exactly the same the
separation our life is in those nine
percent of their thoughts because
remember this these magnets are pretty
powerful that's why I'm always saying
that your obsessions become your
possessions because they do you draw
into your life exactly what it is you
think about it's a physical reality that
you attract to yourself what you think
about so the difference in our life is 9
percent of our thoughts that's why
people say all the time the difference
between winning and losing is so small
it's almost too scary to talk about and
really we have identified what it is
it's 9 percent of what we think about
alters the direction of our life so what
I'm here to tell you today is you've got
to hone in and/or get aware of what you
think about and then alter those 9
percent of the thoughts that are
variable on a daily basis to serve you
if you want to see the affirmation for
success video we did on Gary Vaynerchuk
check out the video right there next to
me I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there the
number one mistake that people are
making in life today and it's and it's
just so unbelievably obvious is they're
living life in the middle